Komm morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sommer Wer ist denn jetzt eigentlich Präsident des deutschen Verfassungsschutzes.
Also in der Lügenpresse steht der wird zu,
getreten worden aber das ist nach wie vor Hans-Georg.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer,
sich heute mal live auf der Bühne wir sind zu Gast,
der Preis ist ewig in Wien und wir begrüßen die zahlreichen Gäste hallo willkommen.
Gallienus dich habe ich auch schon begrüßt.
Ja heute morgen.
Direkt sehen wie du dich gefreut hast.
Ehrlich was sagen guten Morgen.
Ja wir sind im wir sind groß geworden wir sind dem Ruf gerne gefolgt,
ein wenig an dem Programm teilzunehmen zum ist seit gestern,
und schon dafür haben heute auch zahlreiche gestern mit am Start und die jetzt schon alle vorstellen machen oder.
Für dich sofort machen aber ich möchte vorher eine nein das Lob das Logbuch Lob der Woche geht an Alexander Heimbach.
In der letzten Sendung habe ich ja quasi festgestellt dass der Kohlenpott,
Bilder in den Kapitelmarken hatte der Webplayer die aber nicht angezeigt hat,
das war irgendwie wenige Stunden nach der Veröffentlichung gefixt,
und er tötete nur kurze also wir könnten auch in Zukunft gerne,
Bug Report über die Sendung machen würde dann sich zeitnah drum kümmern und das ist ein das ist eine Qualität von,
von Arbeit die hier nicht unerwähnt lassen kann deswegen möchte ich da meine ausraste Anerkennung,
für diese schnelle Reaktion loswerden und vor allem dass er trotzdem freundlich geblieben ist weil das glaube ich wäre ich nicht gewesen wenn mich jemand ist ein Podcast einfach.
Insofern der Typ ist wirklich fit und das hat man auch in der aktuelle Freakshow da wo er nicht wahrnimmt gerade wieder zu Gast zusammen.
So so ist es ja das kann ich alles nur unterstreichen und packreport über Handy Sendungen,
ablassen es auch ganz genau mein Kanal.
Aber jetzt zu den zu den also die Bühne ist voll wie nie glaube ich so seine volle Bühne hatten wir bei einem Logbuch noch nicht.
Die haben sogar hier den Thomas sitzen wir gar nicht erst mal gar kein Mikrofon gegeben zu den komme später denn.
Ladies first.
Wir haben Claudia da Claudia du bist so die,
Die Datenschutzbeauftragte der privacy week.
Ja schon auch also nein das ganze Team,
also ich bin ja nur jetzt gerade mal stellvertretend fürs ganze Team einfach da,
tatsächlich seit 2016 in der Projektleitung hier und also dazu zu sagen wie machen die ganze privacy wird seit 2016 und bis jetzt hat mich noch keiner erschlagen das ist auch nicht so schlecht.
Nimm einfach als Kompliment und ja also Datenschutzfragen und so für Webseite und so weiter man natürlich vorher auch alle mal durch.
Und außerdem haben wir da war er durchaus der privacy Wikipedia wollten wir schon mal so viele kompetente Person vor Ort haben paskuda.
Han.
Ich studiere Informatik auf der TU Wien und mein Themengebiet ist Ungerechtigkeit in Algorithmen und genau deswegen war ja auch auf der privacy.
Schiedsgerichte Algorithmen.
Wie war noch mal diese diese definitions Schwelle für Algorithmus in dem Moment wo wird der Programmierers auch nicht mehr versteht oder oder würde sie wenn das Unternehmen ist nicht mehr versteht was der programmiert wurde oder.
Da gibt's den Spruch ja Algorithmus ist es wenn die Person dich programmiert hat nicht erklären kann oder will was da genau passiert defekt ist natürlich anders aber.
Der kommt wieder.
Ganz viel los ist und alle fragen sich was denn da eigentlich los ist aber der letzte der es wusste ist vor 10 Minuten gegangen.
Ein bisschen bei Software ist das manchmal auch ähnlich.
Meine neue Nummer noch mal kurz erläutern was so die Privacy 1,
habe sie weg so ausgemacht hat so und vielleicht auch in diesem Jahr ausmachen wir haben ja die Veranstaltung angekündigt und so aber,
vielleicht mal so ein bisschen drücken Sie noch mal kurz schildern Claudia was ist so der Inhalt dass der in.
Ja also als wir 2016 den Chaos Computer Club Wien re gründet haben war das eins der zwei Projekte die wir halt quasi relativ zu an.
Gestartet haben das eine war Chaos macht Schule das war das hier nach Wien geholt haben und das andere eben die Privacy Weg Schultern eines übrigens der Jürgen ich weiß nicht ob er gerade noch im Saal ist,
gut ansonsten Herr weiß dass er schuld ist der kam halt mit der Idee um die Ecke er möchte gerne,
er hatte so die Vorstellung privacy week wäre ja eine coole Veranstaltung und das sollte man mal machen,
und ursprünglich war da mal das Konzept wir nehmen vorhandene Veranstaltung sowas wie den netzparameter Day und so weiter was es hier in Wien alles vorher schon gab also netzpolitischer Abend,
das ganze ist man leicht eskaliert als wir in ca 4 ausgeschrieben haben da hatten wir dann 2016 schon 64 Einzelveranstaltung letztendlich während der Woche,
zum Thema Privatsphäre im digitalen Zeitalter 2017 Monster über 90,
dieses Jahr sind wir so bei etwas über 70 Einzelveranstaltungen das heißt wir haben Vorträge.
Ja halt auch blöd Workshops für Kinder hatten wir jetzt auch dabei,
und alles eben wie gesagt um das Thema Privatsphäre,
zugänglicher zu machen und das ist eigentlich auch das was uns,
von einer sonst typischen Chaos Veranstaltung unterscheidet also es sind ja relativ viele Chaos Menschen gerade da weil wir jetzt zeitgleich auch gerade das Bundestreffen Chaos macht Schule hier in Wien haben,
ich sehe da ganz viele Menschen und ich will jetzt wie winkelschild das werdet ihr jetzt halt auch hier vor Ort gemerkt haben wir haben bisschen anderes Publikum das heißt wir haben so sehr gemischt,
Kauf Publikum cars Family aber halt auch Mainstream Publikum und das ist so das was uns auch letztendlich unterscheidet von,
Kongress und 2. abgesehen von Besucherzahlen aus ist also bei 350-400 Besucher momentan noch nicht mein hauptsächlich noch.
Der dann auch Mainstreampresse also seid ihr sozusagen mit dem Echo.
Ja wir haben primär tatsächlich momentan,
A1 FM4 wir haben auf dem Standard in der futurezone also er schon,
noch sodini Schicke ran bis was dann mal irgendwie in die Kronen Zeitung oder ins heute schaffen dauert wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen.
Okay aber ja arbeitet dran.
Und es geht tatsächlich eine ganze Woche.
Montag bis Sonntag.
Kartäuser wirklich auch alles durch der Sehne zwischen,
light Dessert ausgerechnet euch auf die Idee wicked eingelassen hat.
Wir wissen auch was an Tag 5 passiert und 6 und 7 Vergleich zu der Running-Gag seit 216 und nee eigentlich nicht,
eigentlich tut uns nicht leid weil wir dadurch halt wirklich viel Info bieten können viele Workshops und viele Vorträge unterbringen können auch,
hier kommen Menschen nicht die sich eine Woche Urlaub nehmen also,
aus dem Chaos ja das freut mich auch schon riesig aber halt die Mainstream Besucher kommen halt ihr dann nach Feierabend vorbei oder am Wochenende und da möchten wir natürlich halt auch,
das Programm dann halt anbieten können.
Quasi so eine etwas niedrigschwelliges Angebot her zusagen musstest Kannst man kann auch einfach mal,
vorbeikommen abends und aha ist auch im Volkskundemuseum Halszyste.
Etwas eigentümlicher Begriff aber also in einem öffentlichen Ort und der hier der Stadt jetzt auch irgendwie bekannt.
Und so von den Besucherzahlen würde ich sagen noch so ein zwei Jahre schaffen es hier auf jeden Fall auch noch und danach wenn das dann halt weiter kontinuierlich wächst dann müssen wir halt mal schauen wo wir dann hingehen bis zum Messegelände dauert es noch also.
Aber 2-3 Jahren ist Messe Leipzig wieder frei dann passt ja Kongresshalle nicht mehr weit.
Don carne.
Aber eine Idee die ja sogar schon in Berlin jetzt auch kopiert wurde dann sylvelin ist jetzt auch dabei eine privacy week hochzuziehen und.
Immer nur sehr deutlich erfolgreicher als wir mit diesem Staat Konzept und einer von denen von der Pfeife Südberlin war auch hier bis gestern Abend.
Kleines tri-spinner Alchemist Norma.
Ja aber ich glaube das ist es ist grundsätzlich eine gute Sache dass das Thema überhaupt,
behandelt wird halt auch wie gesagt mit diesem niederschwelligen Einschnitt Einstieg weil,
Verkauf Publikum Leute wir wissen alle was wir tun sollten zumindest ja
aber bis das Thema in die breite Masse sichert das hat er ja jetzt auch der der Markus Beckedahl bei der Öffnung der das ist Netzpolitik gesagt das was wir hier diskutieren diskutieren unsere Eltern in 10 Jahren mit dem Mainstream.
Von daher das Thema ist wichtig und das ist auch etwas was wir halt versuchen ebenda mit abzudecken und das ist auch glaube ich der Grund warum wir alle hier wirklich die Woche,
zur Verfügung stellen diese Woche durchprügeln ja so ab Tag 5 wird das nichts aber irgendwann schwierig so auf mit dem Schlafmangel aber.
Nee das ist glaube ich so der der Motor der das ganze Team als auch,
dazu bringt das wirklich diese Woche halt zu machen.
Sollen vielleicht an der Stelle auch noch mal erwähnen es gab ja auch noch an oder gibt sogar auch noch eine langlaufende Veranstaltung hier in ähnlichen Focus hat die Datenspuren in Dresden habt ihr da auch diplomatische Beziehungen.
Einiges von von uns vom Team haben da BZ hin ich persönlich jetzt tatsächlich noch nicht ich war auch noch nicht dort wer sich dieses Jahr fast ausgegangen aber leider nur fast ich hoffe dass es da auch irgendwann noch mal hin schaffe ja.
Und dann haben wir uns ein Thema rausgesucht das hier auf,
schreibe sie weg eine Rolle gespielt hat nämlich die Algorithmen.
Und in Österreich habe ich mir sagen lassen ist jetzt sogar schon so weit gekommen dass man das ist Algorithmen gibt zur Sortierung von Arbeitslosen.
Arbeitssuchenden bei einem spezifischen nur die KlientInnen vom Arbeitsmarktservice ohne mich,
erfasst und bearbeitet werden also nicht alle Menschen die keine Arbeit haben sondern nur die Menschen die dort spezifische hingehen und sich Hilfe holen.
Also muss ich zur Sortierung melden und ausfindig möchte und dann.
Ford oder wie muss ich mir das wie muss ich mir das vorstellen über was wird denn da entschieden.
Entschieden wird darüber nicht wer in den Job kriegt sondern Wer Unterstützung Krieg,
kann nichts schiefgehen bei hat ja noch keiner negative Erfahrungen gemacht damit wir sortieren jetzt halt Menschen nach der Titel.
Und hat die Daten von den vergangenen ich glaube zwei Jahren her genommen und sich angeschaut wie sind die Chancen am Arbeitsmarkt.
Nachdem was für Eigenschaften eine Person hat,
und genau da werden dann die die Arbeitsuchenden in drei Kategorien eingeteilt,
ab&c immerhin nicht nummerierte.
Die Kategorie A sind die Leute die tolle Chancen haben in nichts zweiten Job zu kriegen,
die braucht man nicht großartig fördern die machen das E von selber so ungefähr,
Kategorie Besen leutewitzer bisschen schwieriger da muss man dann schon ein bisschen mehr Geld aufwenden ever,
cose Zahlen domeetv dontop kriegen und jetzt Kategorie C das sind die Leute die.
Schiff um eine Message Service geht um Effizienzsteigerung ja die Faktur immer noch kein Geld verschwenden.
Man nennt das don't throw good money after Bad.
Ja
Und da wird man dann also mit einem Algorithmus wird die Personen,
Algorithmus klassifiziert und wenn sie Pech hat ist sie A oder C.
Ja genau also ja exaktes und dann kriegt man halt keine Förderung.
Es ist immerhin also Transparenz technisch sind die ganz gut drauf die haben inkomplettes also,
macht sitzt sie ja genau du willst dann interessant weil er mir,
dürfte bei Ihnen einfach überhaupt nicht das ist bei uns auch restless sehr bedenklich weil die Faktor ist so dass man halt auf Basis vom Wohnsitz Punktabzüge Krieg,
auf Basis von der Staatsbürgerschaft Punktabzüge kriegt auf Basis der ersten Sprache Punktabzüge.
Und der fuckboys sodass bei gleicher berechne bei bei gleicher Qualifikation Männer Frauen gegenüber bevorzugt werden.
Den Algorithmus.
Durch die Tatsache dass es halt am Arbeitsmarkt zu ist.
Wir schreiben einfach den Status Quo ma fest dann ist es auch mal.
Wunderbar wunderbar willst dann wenn es heißt Betreuungspflichten geben auch in Abzug aber nur für Frauen.
Also also einmal das ist ja so.
Alles alles drin.
Ich geschafft so alle klassischen diskriminierungs Kategorien da einfach auch mal ganz ein.
Ja ja genau also ist jetzt nicht dieses klassische machine-learning Dings und Entwicklung einfach nur Statistik und mir schauen an was für Parameter und das nur umdrehen müssen damit Leute weniger guten Job.
Meiner Meinung nach auch sehr aufschlussreich ist die Tatsache dass halt die Standard Person von der ausgegangen wird und von gestern Abzüge irgendwie Mitte 20 weiß männlich ist.
Also humans Tavannes Stadt machine learning.
Da kommst du jetzt zu den drei österreichischen Grundsätzen ja das war nie so das ist nicht so und,
könnt ja jeder kommen also.
Und also die die der Grund warum das ist ich sitze in einer gewissen,
Ecke Würde zurück behaupten also edelswiss sie ist Claudia vorhin aufgezählt hat Standard futurezone A1 und ich glaub FM4 also Eden.
Hier schon,
wie zerlegt worden also das sind Leute von allen möglichen Unis die sagen,
Ghizzoni stoßen Leute die forschen,
nebenan Gerechtigkeit in Inso Autohaus in Entscheidungs unterstützungs.
Sind aber jetzt auch die Medien die jetzt schon von von dem von der aktuellen Regierung keine keine Infos mehr kriegen sollen oder die werden nicht mehr eingeladen zu.
Kriege schon Infos aber halt nur in einem an einem angebrachten Maß.
Glaube das war die Formulierung na aber die Argumentation vom vom Chef vom vom vom AMS vom herrnkopf ist dann halt auch.
Der Algorithmus des System gibt ja keine also das fällt dir keine Entscheidungen sondern das unterstützt.
Also das klingt doch eigentlich nach einer also man hat also wir sehen alle fehl,
Argumentation und Überlegungen an einem an einer Ort an einem Ort und einer Stelle.
Wenn da jetzt sogar die Ungerechtigkeiten dokumentiert sind was eigentlich ein bewundernswerter Fortschritt ist gegenüber anderen Situationen amazon hat Sonnensystem über,
besprochen haben jahrelang Blackrock,
betrieben bis sie gemerkt habe nachher das dem haben wir irgendwie beigebracht keine,
Bewerberinnen einzuladen deswegen ist ja alles voller Männer,
okay komischer Sie die Konten ja wenigstens noch sagen anevia wir sind ja nur eines der führenden Unternehmen auf dem Bereich von Cloud Computing und er ja aber ansonsten haben wir ja kaum,
irgendwie kann man es ja kaum einen Vorwurf machen dass wir so ein Mist machen hier ist jetzt alles dokumentiert das riecht doch Eigentor des klingt doch nach.
Das ist irgendwie eigentlich den den lach Test nicht bestehen sollte und damit auch umgehend Weg geklagt werden kann.
Also also meine Meinung noch könnt man das System super benutzen um am Arbeitsmarkt Dinge zu verändern ja wir hatten wir sehen doch ganz eindeutig was sind die,
Dorn Dieter Arbeitsmarkt im Moment benachteiligt wo sollten wir womöglich mit Gesetzen was tun aber mit unserer Akte,
hierum ist es halt irgendwie so eher nicht.
Wer hat sich denn den Spaß einfallen lassen ist das jetzt was ganz Neues oder ist das eigentlich schon so länger am werden oder gab es da noch mal im Reinigungs hör auch gerade sehr populär.
Es ist schon mal versucht worden vor paar Jahren was nicht mehr genau wann das war der damalige verantwortliche Sozialminister hatte gesagt nee gar keinen Fall und das Projekt ist jetzt.
14 Monate lang laufen also man kann die klassische Rück,
Rechnung machen und sagen sojo geht es war im November letztes Jahr und.
Wo man das wirklich so richtig angeschoben hat das ist passiert also Monate nach der Nationalratswahl.
Ich habe hatte da die Regierung jetzt in dem Arbeitsmarkt wie heißt die Behörde noch mal kurz.
Arbeitsmarktservice.
Was magst Du wissen haben die da noch so haben wir noch so Upgrades gemacht oder ist das erstmal entkoppeln.
Also dort ist meines Wissens nach nicht großartig Personaler Setz wurden aber was halt ist es halt so die generelle Budget kürzer Reise ganz gerade in sozialen Ecke.
Und wenn es dann halt heißt Setz also wir geben euch weniger Geld sitzt das was ihr habt effizienter eine Hey warte mal ist doch Alkohol.
Das Schlimme ist dass die im Zweifelsfall argumentieren können dass sie,
die gleichen Entscheidung auch ohne den Algorithmus treffen würden jetzt nur schneller.
Die Aussage vom von Johannes Kopf dazu war dass der Algorithmus tendenziell positiver den Leuten gegenüber eingestellt.
Wenn der Algorithmus schon sagt du bist ein sehr großer Mensch dann brauchen wir glaube ich einen Menschen gar nicht mehr draufklicken zulassen.
Keine Ahnung also es ist also dieses XI interviewte,
auf IV Song mit ihm macht worden jetzt ist die Links sollten dann ähneln schon uns,
ich habe regelmässig Pausen machen müssen wenn man Kopfweh tarn hat vom face Parmen.
Weil wirklich also jedes jedes Ding des Forschung im Bezug auf,
alles in algorithms schon festgestellt hat wird in diesem nach aufgebracht,
und er singt jedesmal ab und sagt in Österreich anders.
Du hast es ja sehr eigentlich gerade schon gesagt ich finde nur noch mal drauf noch mal drauf zurückkommen das sind eigentlich politische Entscheidungen.
Definitiv.
Und man also ist kalt ist konnte irgendwie die Entscheidung getroffen werden ok,
wir sagen nun politische Maßgabe Förderung dieser oder jener Personengruppe.
Was jedes Mal auch eine diskriminierende Entscheidung ist dir wenigstens auf irgendeine Weise.
Legitim oder nicht aber irgendwie eine politische Basis hat das eben die Entscheidung getroffen wird das wird jetzt gefördert oder nicht.
Aber dann noch mal sogar extra noch mal zusagen der Nähe wir nehmen einfach die replizieren einfach nur die Vergangenheit ja wir replizieren unsere vergangenen Erfahrungen das klingt mir so nachdem,
es ist so so so so öffentlich klar habe ich auch.
Und die dir die Geschichte geht ja weiter das dass Dummkopf daneben sagt.
Algorithmus vorgegeben Harz und die können ja auch eine Umstufung vornehmen.
Müssen Sie nur einen längeren Bericht zu schreiben warum sie sich gegen den Computer entschieden haben.
Das Büro Catia will gefüttert werden haargenau und es ist so absolut unklar wie es ausschaut mit Wörtern die die Arbeitsuchenden dagegen wehren können.
Gamma keine Förderung mehr.
Also keine Ahnung wenn man hat den Verdacht hat dass man,
Verdacht man kann sie ja man kann sie ja im Endeffekt herauslesen aus diesem Modell des veröffentlicht worden ist auf welchen Gründen dass man,
diskriminiert worden ist aber eben die Frage ist kriegt man dann die Bestätigung quasi vom AMS ja hey du wohnst im falschen Bezirk in Wien und deswegen kriegt Konkurs.
Es wird ein Logbuch Netzpolitik credit card wir sind dagegen und wir packen das an.
Mich würde tatsächlich interessieren was was wird jetzt in Österreich dagegen getan also das ist ja relativ eindeutig dass dass das nicht gehen kann sowas muss von Verfassungsgericht oder sonstiges und es muss dann weg.
Interessensvertretungen im Großen und Ganzen Salz die Würde eines Leuten die ich weiß halt nicht um was im vorhinein schon einklagen kannte sie sich die Schwierigkeit,
aber ab nächsten Jahr oder so was könnte man dann damit,
zur arbeit da kann man gehen bzw zu Gewerkschaften zur Gleichbehandlungsanwaltschaft wir haben ja zum Glück aparso Einrichtungen die dafür da wären so Sachen.
Und dann müsste der.
Vertreten das müsste doch.
10 bis es dann irgendwann heiß.
Kann sich nur um Jahre handeln.
Bitte schön und hatte ab.
Spastik.
Kannst du noch ein paar Vorträge drüber halten.
Es wäre schön wenn seine richtigen Stelle ankommt ist eh gehabt jetzt dann hahnkopf z.b. heute nicht in meinem Talk gesehen es war eigentlich ganz,
sinnvoll informieren würde mein Angebot steht andere Kollegen haben genauso schon,
man könnte mal drüber reden.
Aber insgesamt auch ein Ding das man hier hält eigentlich häufig beobachten kann also die,
beratungsresistent ist durchaus vorhanden und ausgeprägt also wir sind jetzt hier grundsätzlich mit dem Volkskundemuseum was das Fußweg 7 Minuten so Richtung Parlament runter oder
also soweit ist es alles nicht ja und außer ein paar,
Wetter in der Stadt Wien oder Vertreterinnen konkret,
am hat sich jetzt zumindest hier bei der privacy zumindest noch nicht wie,
lassen oder zumindest ändern inkognito aber.
Einladung hinschicken oder summ Schnittchen anbieten irgend so ein Schnittchen Empfang machen.
Hashtag nächstes Jahr hin.
Dann kommen die Angebote zur Beratung haben wir in Deutschland auch und zwar haben wir ja auch so eine relativ neue Partei.
Also so neu scheint die gar nicht zu sein.
Nee die ist also ausfällt.
Die gab's schon mal.
Die hatten wir schon mal.
Neuen Version.
Mal wieder gekommen die hat sich jetzt rebooted 2.0 die haben also gesagt sie mal sie sie schaffen jetzt weil irgendwo irgendwie zu Ohren gekommen ist das unter Umständen Lehrerinnen,
den Kindern sagen sie sollten nicht die AFD wählen und dass sie sagt das kann ja wohl nicht sein,
bisschen Lehrerin in die politische Einflussnahme auf unsere Nichtberechtigten Kinder nehmen und die Schülerinnen und Schüler,
oder und deren Eltern sollten bitte auf einer Webseite von der AFD betrieben wird Lehrerin oder Lehrer melden die die AFD kritisieren.
Und wenn dann nach Prüfung der gemeldeten Lehrerin ein begründeter Anfangsverdacht besteht dann würde die,
allzu darüber in Kenntnis zu setzen.
Da irgendwie Personen,
offenbar politische Einflussnahme auf die Kinder nehmen und ich habe mir,
persönlich hat mir irgendwie darüber nachgedacht. Tatsächlich ist das ein gewisses,
am Problemfeld wenn wir da Lehrerin haben die den die die Kinder in in in Richtung bestimmter Parteien drängen find das natürlich wichtig dass die,
demokratische Grundwerte vermitteln und dazu gehört in Zweifelsfällen 45t aufgeben aber.
Umgekehrt finde ich es ja auch empörend wenn eine Lehrerin,
ich CSU wählen ja oder sowas,
ärgerlich natürlich oder spannen natürlich wenn sich dann eine Partei entscheidet wir bieten diesen Dienst an,
meldet uns mal die Lehrerin und wir schauen uns die wir schauen jetzt sie dann mal an,
ich weiß nicht ob man sowas überhaupt da sie noch nie so du bist du kennst ja mit Datenschutz ausgelastet.
Also was was wie muss ich die wie kann ich mir das vorstellen also ist er ist sowas legal.
Kann ich mir jetzt mal Grundsätze.
Sind meine Daten da sicher bei der Alf.
Hat das schonmal jemand hier im Raum ge.
Tatsächlich Rückfrage hier ans Publikum hat sich jemand mal Diesel,
Seite angeschaut und geguckt wie sicher das Ding ist und wenn.
Mehrere gemacht da komme ich gleich noch mal.
Okay super ja also nee ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das in irgendeiner Art sicher oder lecker heiß sein kann aber.
Dann nehme ich auch gerne den den Rat der Experten.
Thomas willst du was sagen dann darfst du meinen Kopfhörer haben.
Gehört und eine gemacht aber so schnell dazwischen zu switchen ist neu,
also ich war zuerst mal das prinzipielle das natürlichen chilling effect,
haben wir gleich den Segway zur FPÖ die FPÖ hat ja bei der AFD schon den Vertrag Gehalt muss er genau das gesagt,
abend behaltet euch die Listen auf und den Linken die gegen euch demonstrieren wenn wir dann an der Macht sind,
Andersson wir jetzt in vielen Staaten schon gesehen dass das auch gerade in der Türkei in Justiz Sektor im Bildungssektor dann ganz schnell passieren kann ich sag jetzt nicht dass das in Deutschland übermorgen passiert aber die Logik ist dieselbe,
alabis datenschutzrechtlich Case kann man so nicht glaube ich nicht brutal sagen,
solltest da schon eine Möglichkeit geben auch wenn das jetzt nicht immer gleich der Staat sein muss.
Und ich weiß es z.b. das auf EU Ebene 1 erstes Gesetz zum whistleblowerschutz gibt was aber noch nicht fertig ist und das würde wahrscheinlich dann auch unter dieser recht.
Ist das jetzt nur Anmeldeformular also und und es sind die dann,
geschickt den Namen und nicht öffentlich einsehbar oder geht das dann gleich mal in so eine öffentliche Liste wo man dann alle Namen sieht weil das ist dann ja datenschutzrechtlich garantiert nicht.
Also direkt öffentlich wird es nicht nein das ist wirklich getan dass man nur an die AFD und dann Nachprüfung an die Schulbehörden des jeweiligen Landes,
zusagen.
Die Prüfung durch die AFD ist deshalb notwendig weil da mehrere Protestformen stattgefunden haben unter anderem gab es dann eine Webseite ich glaube unter der Domäne.
Mein Abgeordneter hetzt oder so wo,
kein ordentlichen Schutz für Ihre Seite hatten was kostet request forgery oder sowas angeht dass sie jetzt auf einer anderen Seite Inhalte formulierst die dann,
Diehl an deren Seite gemeldet werden oder gabs dann einfach so Standard Dinger wie ich möchte hätte von Alexander gauland melden der dann irgendwie mal wieder,
irgendwo ein Mikrofon Gerüst hat und die Night of service Angriff verschieden da,
zu finden weil das Ding dann irgendwie relativ schnell wieder offline waren,
also ist natürlich auch ich habe auch drüber nachgedacht ob man so nah ob man so eine.
PR Stunt auch überhaupt.
Gegnern möchte indem man den hier in der Sendung in die besprechen den wir dem also sowas ernst nehmen die werden natürlich im Zweifelsfall hoffentlich keine sinnvollen,
Daten darüber sammeln können weil sich immer jemand findet irgendwelchen Stuss einträgt und ich kann mir genug Schülerinnen oder Schüler vorstellen die denn da einfach auch ihren Lehrerin sagen immer also die die drei Unternehmen,
deutsche Aufsatz die sich nicht so,
und ich könnte mir vorstellen dass ich das einfach der AFD jetzt melde so und das also diese das als als droht Finale auch aufzubringen.
Komparativ sicher sind Wiesental sozusagen.
Werde doch nicht also.
Anmelden.
Genau bin ich der AFD melden es geht hier um Aufmerksamkeit Erzeugung und kennt diesen Zyklus das ist halt irgendwie Trump,
in Reinform anschreit einfach irgendwas raus man macht irgendwelche Sachen wo alles Atze wie das geht gar nicht und so und schon diktiert man halt die Öffentlichkeit sind ein relativ,
klug gespieltes Spiel so und sicherlich,
stehen wir so alt intellektuell ausgewogene Menschen immer so ein bisschen dieser Zwickmühle das wäre eigentlich dieses Spiel so nicht mitspielen wollen aber solange wir es halt nicht auch spielen eigentlich immer nur verlieren.
Was mich am meisten an diesem Ding oder was mich am nebenbei,
Essanelle scheiße aktionist ich sehe das,
die rechte ist immer mehr schafft so Strategien des politischen protests in irgendeiner from anzuwenden,
die vorher also die vor einigen Jahren auch mal sind,
Beweise Neuwaren und innovativ fahren und dafür auch im Intellekt gebraucht haben denn.
Ich weiß nicht wie diese Aktion also diese Aktion wird irgendwie hängen oder den Zentrum für,
bitteschön hat nichts unterstellen und das wäre in etwas abgewandelter Form etwas gewesen was auch von denen hätte kommen können,
am Hang hat er jetzt auch gerade diese copenhell des geht in eine sehr ähnliche Richtung wo man also Polizisten Präsenz,
melden kann und die dann irgendwie veröffentlicht wird es geht in eine sehr ähnliche Richtung gibt 1000 Unterschiede dazwischen aber beides sind irgendwie wird grau wir Crowdsourcing jetzt mal was und diese,
wir wissen dass das was wir da tun in irgendeiner Form eine emotionale Reaktion herbeiruft und deswegen wissen wir dass wir damit eine politische Debatte über ein Thema in irgendeiner formen.
Aber es funktioniert aber nur für das funktioniert nur für die bösen sozusagen ja weil
diese krasse Wahrzeichen wenn sie kommt maps für mich Aldi auf wieder so ein Ding,
Polizeizentrale müssen die Gesetze verschärfen wenig es damit gewonnen werden wir auf unserer Seite er so ein Höhe das war bei Görtz lustig hier.
Die sagt zu der ihm genauso viel Öffentlichkeit bekommen hat feel the pain.
Was ich noch sagen wollte dass dieses die Rechten übernehmen auch Aktionsformen recht intensiv von also die Uhr.
Ja die versuchen.
Wir müssen uns auch darauf einrichten dass wir das vielleicht in 34 Jahren dann auch mal richtig hinkriegen also bisher ist es ja immer noch so bemitleidenswerte,
ein bisschen plump Aktion aber dir muss ich darauf einrichten dass die besser werden und es ist auch
Bewerbung günstige Annahme davon aus,
gehen das ist überhaupt etwas wir eine linke Aktionsform gebe,
die auch einfache Menschen nicht zumindest schlecht kopieren könnten und in die andere Richtung weg.
Gutes und großes Problem dabei war ja jetzt auch die längste Zeit das deshalb.
Gut verwertbare Bilder erzeugen und das dann halt in den Medien zerfiel die Bildsprache von den von den Rechten dann,
Aussprache von den Rechten London reproduziert wird Unterhalt Audi message ist dann wieder überall landen sehr.
Sowas in Österreich eigentlich auch schon.
Diese dieses Jahr die diese Lehrerinnen melde Seite hat die,
über uns auch schon mal probiert zu 1017 reden also letztes Jahr,
da hat's am Vortag geben an der oberösterreichischen Schule von am Extremismus,
und dann hat explizit,
Parallelen aufgezeigt hat zwischen der FPÖ und diversen rechtsextremen Gruppierungen dies an die neue Blicke.
Und davor Tage ich dann unterbrochen worden weil,
irgendwie,
sind wir das Zonen von irgendwem,
und kurze Zeit später ist dann auf dich dann die Website parteifreie Schule aufgetaucht wo halt,
das klassische Ding gespielt wurde nicht von wegen ja da hat's Partei Inhalte geben und die Schule muss neutral bleiben und objektiv bleiben war echt schnell offline und die Domain de linkedin also,
Leiter II auf die Website von oberösterreichische FPÖler aber hat sie auch schon gegeben.
Die Vorlagen werden dann immer fleißig.
Geteilt ja voll.
Ja paskuda wir tauschen dich jetzt mal aus,
vielen Dank dass du bei uns warst.
Ja danke für die Einladung.
Ja wir leiden leider unter Headset und Mikrofon Mangel.
5 Uhr läuten Hunger jetzt nicht gerechnet so Thomas jetzt bist du auch offiziell dabei.
Also.
Herzlich willkommen wo warst du denn.
Ich komme gerade von London ich war noch auf dem motzfest dass es so das jährliche
wenn von Mozilla riesige Konferenz in London und war aber auch ganz nett und eigentlich auch passend zum Thema also ganz viel Deter dann weiter so das Motto und
sehr viel Daten Ethik das ist jetzt gerade auch so das große Thema das sieht sich ja gerade durch.
Also.
Adnight ist Mozilla hat ja immer noch irgendwie so diesen Maker Anspruch und du hast sie doch immer noch ganz viel hands-on was passiert aber sie haben heute auch irgendwie cooles polnische Team holen sich da auch wirklich weltweit weiter rein,
also das ist wirklich noch globale Konferenz,
Arndt ja aber jetzt zu Web natürlich ist es ein Browser der irgendwie im Zentrum von der Firma,
aber die Firma Antwort hat die Foundation hinter der Firma eigentlich versucht schon mehr zu machen.
Locken.
First things first.
Und ja es war noch eine andere Veranstaltung,
suche wir haben heute den 27 Oktober 2018,
die globale Konferenz der Datenschutzbeauftragten.
AAA CDP PC ist der Nachfolger von PCMCIA.
Ungefähr ja.
The international conference of data protection,
privacy Commission as da treffen sich die Kommissionäre Kommissare.
Man merkt schon irgendwie dass das Ganze im Europaparlament stattgefunden hat oder es ist sehr Behörden nal und Datenschutzbeauftragte wann irgendwie es vor kurzem noch gar nicht cool,
außerhalb von Bad schon kannte man dass er glaube ich weiß gar nicht und jetzt auf einmal sind die wichtig so wichtig dass sogar irgendwie der,
von Apple Tim Cook dorthin kommt um einen Park zu halten wo er recht viel Aufsehen erzeugt hat damit,
A-Team Kuchen hat Tim Cook hat sich dort nämlich sehr stark eigentlich.
Gutes Marketing oder.
Und naja vielmals nicht anders erwarten kann von seiner Apple Keynote ja das war's auch ne man merkte das war gut formuliert alles auf den Punkt gebracht aber,
ich saß da die ganze Zeit und musste halt nicken weil er erstmal hat er natürlich die dsgvo,
gelobt und das Parlament dafür blobe ich das so durchgedrückt zu haben da am Ball zu bleiben,
meint das wäre halt ein sehr wichtiges Element hat mehr nur auch nicht unbedingt immer das so Lobbyisten daher kommen und sagen wir auch voll geil das Gesetz hier und so für die Bürger,
bringt unsere Arbeit irgendwie signifikant 1 und ne,
Fußfesseln an normalerweise läuft das ja in die andere Richtung,
wird das formuliert weaponized against als also das sozusagen eine diese diese diese Daten greifen an,
und wenn wir eine Waffe gegen Menschen eingesetzt und dagegen hat er sich stark ausgesprochen.
Vor allem natürlich auch für die also,
Berlin sicher daran an den Militär industriellen Komplex military-industrial complex den White Eisenhower in seiner Abschiedsrede als Präsident nehmen ist,
Eisenhower war general bevor er Präsident wurde nerve der jetzt irgendwie militärisch als Pazifist,
bezog er sich denn einen 60 auf die Allianz zwischen,
Regierung und Rüstungsindustrie,
in Deutschland gerne so ein bisschen totgeschwiegen wird und gut funktioniert.
Und,
sprich damit an dass diese Rüstungsindustrie Sushi,
geworden ist dass sie die die die Politik,
der Regierung leitet und und lenkt und der Begriff 1961 von Eisenhower gesetzt ist
heute noch allen Menschen irgendwie Begriff hat man dann schon mal eben gehört ne und sich daran,
also diese dieser Vergleich halt ist schon denk ich aus der bezeichnet.
Der alte hat das ja auch in seiner Abschiedsrede er hat wirklich die Öffentlichkeit davor gewarnt.
Cimco Kati aber nicht.
Noch nicht nee ich hoffe auch nicht weil ich glaube der macht dann ganz guten Job
Amon ja aber ich bin Kunde hat er ja auch irgendwie so,
Hintergrund besprochen haben umbenannt als die Konsequenz von Algorithmen Profiling das halt Massivhaus personenbezogener Daten zurückgreift und,
mit alldem Haare eigentlich und das war der große politische.
Eigentlich die USA aufgefordert auch ein datenschutz-grundverordnung mäßiges Gesetz zu erlassen.
Und ich nur irgendein sollen möglichst alles was so ist.
Genau er hat doch noch vier Prinzipien genannt das so irgendwie stark die Richtung,
tot ist überhaupt ein Grundrecht ja das ist für die Amerikaner ja auch irgendwie nicht selbstverständlich,
ah doch jetzt hier nur so die ABBA,
H&M das hat sich da so stark auf eine Seite stellt,
weil der Hauptkonkurrent von Apple ist Google im gerätemarkt,
facebook ist ja gar natürlich ganz klar angesprochen die waren auch im Raum,
ich habe von Leuten sagen dass.
Und das heißt es macht doch aus auf von der Business Logik Kerstin,
gleichzeitig die USA sind ja auch nicht der first Follower sondern wir haben in Indien als neues Datenschutzgesetz
sind verabschiedet ist aber das ist sehr stark an die datenschutzgrundverordnung angelehnt in Afrika gibt's auch schon Vorstöße in die Richtung also Europa hatte wirklich eine Welle gestartet,
und das ist gut dass es wirklich so,
die beste Vision von Europa wenn wir für für für Grundrechte irgendwie zukunftsfähige Lösungen erstellen die dann auch auf dem Rest der Welt sich durchsetzen können.
Ja an der Stelle, vielleicht auch noch mal mit uns auf unser Gespräch mit Jan Philipp Albrecht verweisen weil obwohl,
Musik 256 auch auf der Bühne da mir das ja auch angesprochen diesen Einfluss sind im zusammen noch ganz.
Achtet im Eisenacher und Albrecht das ist.
Eisenhower und Albrecht in die Zukunft was sind 7 Sachen noch kann,
das Hand finde ist ja was wir man glaube ich nicht so richtig veränderlichen ist das in USA,
die der Blick der Gesellschaft auf Unternehmen versus,
start zumindest Passdaten betrifft im Prinzip genau,
ausgetauscht ist ja hier,
habe vor allem Angst dass Firmen die Daten nutzen und sehen da sehr viel mehr das Heil dafür eine staatliche Ordnung zu finden während in den,
mit Waffen ausgestatteten Bürgern,
Amerikas eben immer sehr viel mehr die Angst vor dem Allmächtigen Staat da,
aber man eben eigentlich sehr viel mehr Vertrauen in die Unternehmen hat die so immer das repräsentieren was du America stark gemacht
na so unsere Unternehmen das sind ja wir und so und insofern ist interessant dass Tim Cook als Repräsentant des mächtigsten Unternehmens derzeit in der USA als wissen was jetzt
Geldfluss betrifft also Einfluss vielleicht das falsche Wort aber Sauerwald auf jede Vereine der sichtbarsten
Unternehmen und fähigsten Unternehmen an dieser Stelle eigentlich genau die gegenteilige Haltung einnimmt.
Das tut er jetzt allerdings auch nicht erst seit zwei Wochen oder sowas sondern die Position vertreten sie ja auch schon seit einer ganzen Weile was ja auch eigentlich gut so ist.
Schon steve Jobs hat das im Prinzip genauso formuliert.
Am Walter steck doch noch irgendwie ein anderes Pack drin dir da wen hat nämlich diese ganze Cybersecurity Daten Sicherheitsaspekt wo hat auch gemeint hat es ist die Verantwortung von Apple,
die Sicherheit der Geräte und auch die die Integrität der Daten der Leute das Vertrauen in die seitlichen,
ruf zu halten und das auch gegenüber anderen führen und gegenüber starten zu verteidigen,
auch wiederum perfekte Apple-Keynote ja er hat hiermit auch wiederum Ihr Produkt beworben mit dem was es abgrenzt gegenüber.
Und auch hochgehalten.
Ja genau ich bin hier das neue ich habe schon eins.
Amazing.
The missing.
Gleichzeitig werden wir natürlich schon das Apple eine der Firmen ist die sich dagegen wehrt Vektor sind die eigenen Produkte Einzug,
mit Hardware Zugriffe versucht das Gerät sichergestellt hat man noch drauf zugreifen konnte,
diese Lücke haben sie jetzt geschlossen sei erinnert auch an den San Bernardino Case wo sie sich ja auch geweigert.
Genau also die gehen ja noch weiter also da kommst du auch in den Bereich wo dann teilweise.
Auch widersprochen wird sie gehen ja quasi weil Weg von der also Datensammlung massiv sowieso schon mal nicht aber bis zu dem Punkt das jetzt ein beschlagnahmtes Gerät,
immer noch die Privatsphäre der Nutzerinnen schützt auch
in den Händen von Strafverfolgungsbehörden beim San Bernardino Case als eben das FBI und zuletzt gab es diese Schwachstelle oder dieses dieses Produkt vielmehr mit dem Namen,
greykey graykey.
Wo quasi durch Manipulation und ich sind USB-Anschluss genau das gemacht wurde was in dem San Bernardino Case die,
Angreifer soll ich jetzt als klassischer Security consultant des FBI wollte
erinner mich in Prinzipen Brute-Force-Angriff auf dem Papst Code und Apple ist da regelmäßig irgendwie dran zugange z.b. jetzt mit dem iOS 9 featured I
therapy Referenz anschließen lässt damit auch keine externe Tastatur oder irgendwelche Geräte die es in irgendeiner Form schaffen überhaupt mit dem Dingen zu zu interagieren irgendwelche
das ist natürlich eine sehr effiziente Maßnahme ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher weiß nicht ob Apple das,
wusste dass sie da mit diesem graykey kaputt machen würden definitiv aber es war klar dass sie es damit genau versucht haben und es hat dann auch funktioniert und,
das sind ich bin natürlich immer noch so,
soll ich mal Eisenhauer Albrecht und guck oder so ne aber die,
zumindest solange die PR Welle die Apple da versucht zu reiten eben auch in derartigen Aktionen mündet.
Am finde ich das will ich mich damit sehr wohl und vor allem werden sie in der Lage wenn sie sogar den Mut auf,
bringen für diese PR-Aktion sich halt in bestimmten Kreisen sehr negative Presse.
Also als Netzpolitiker ist das ist doch was ich spaded finde an den ganzen Themenstellungen du hast immer fliegenden Allianzen der Allianzen,
Vanessa 3D ist die Telekom Industrie unser großer Fan und hast.
Überwachungs Themen sind sie eigentlich unsere part,
und wenn er bis sich jetzt hier wirklich so positioniert und die Linie jetzt auch durchzieht dann,
Zahl hatte Konsequenzen wir haben schon mal geredet über dieses australische Access Bill,
muss sozusagen wirklicher Hintertüren verpflichtend gemacht werden müssen das heißt,
Christopher hergestellt Geräte her du musst irgendwie eine Möglichkeit vorsehen,
wieder staatliche Stellen noch rankomme können wenn sich da Apple jetzt kommt mit querstellt dann kann,
doch aus bei dir Debatte rund um dieses Gesetz genau der Apps sein den wir brauchen,
am wenn es wirklich durchziehen.
Aber dann macht mir Sorge dass der Tim Cook dafür ins Europaparlament gehen muss
die anders ist normal ganz anderes Thema dass der Tim guckt sich halt auch überlegt
mit wem hat noch hättet oder nicht aber da ist er sicherlich nicht gerade,
wird sich auch überlegt haben ob er das um ausgerechnet im EU-Parlament sagen musst du,
kann ich vielleicht irgendwo anders eine Möglichkeit findet so etwas zu sagen.
Feichtinger weiß auch schon dass er derzeit im politischen System Mirsada wenig Gehör finden würde.
Ja aber sind bisschen Was gibt's bei ihm ja ihr auch noch nachzubessern wer hat es schon geschafft,
auftragsverarbeitungsvertrag von Apple zu kriegen wer hat's versucht.
Bin ich bin ich weniger hintergehen.
Wer wer arbeitet tatsächlich beruflich mit Apple Geräten das ist im iPhone vielleicht oder so ein zum mehrere Hände.
Was für ein Vertrag soll man.
The fall.
Als nächstes fragte ob ihr eure Kontakte in die iCloud sind.
Oder,
ja also was trägt man denn so ein Kalender ein normalerweise Adressen Telefonnummern gegebenenfalls so Anruf Anja das und wenn man dann halt erlaubt dass das in die iCloud Sync naja dann hat man ein bisschen Problem weil die iCloud ist ein Consumer,
das ist nicht für den gewerblichen Gebrauch vorgesehen da steht in den Apple AGB drin wir sind übrigens hier im Nebenraum auch gerade nachzulesen,
du kriegst momentan kein AVV also auftragsverarbeitungsvertrag nach dsgvo von Apple also da gibt noch ein bisschen was.
Ich muss das ja gar nicht gewerblich Finja Freiburg.
Well.
Ist alles richtig ich denke dass ein Prozess andererseits hat zum guck auch jetzt vor kurzem noch mal gesagt dass sie demnächst,
Stinki der iCloud loswerden wollen also sich sozusagen auch einfach komplett aus den Daten raushalten wollen,
wann,
am aber naja sie werden deine Agenda haben das ist vollkommen klar,
und diese Öffentlichkeitsarbeit dir gerade betreiben ist Alter.
Ein anderes Thema wo uns diese Aussage helfen könnte ist die alte Geschichte über die e-privacy-verordnung.
Ich dachte die habt ihr jetzt auf gebremst hier also eure Regierung die ihr gewählt hat.
Ja das tun sie gerade das.
Kling erste Steine.
Also wir erinnern uns privacy das ist ein Gesetz was auf der datenschutz-grundverordnung auf,
und was noch mal explizit für den Bereich ist wo es um eigentlich Briefgeheimnis geht also Vertraulichkeit der Kommunikation,
aber das betrifft Messenger-Dienste das betrifft der Telekom Betreiber generell da wo mieterdaten anfallen erkennt dieses Gesetz doch als die cookie-richtlinie,
und das wird gerade neu verhandelt und da ist Österreich wiedermal sehr glänzend dabei gar nichts zu tun und bei Datenschutz Themen,
das hat keine Priorität bei der aktuellen schwarzblond Bundesregierung,
und genau da hilft es uns aber auch wenn sich mal wieder so Rückendeckung von der Wirtschaft zu bekommen in dem Thema ist es nämlich so,
dass die Verlagsbranche sogar da auch Springer und ist der Reich der Verband österreichischer Zeitungsverleger in Allianz mit der Werbeindustrie und mit Google und Facebook gerade versuchen dieses Gesetz zu verhindern,
und damit auch genau diese Art von targeted advertising personalisierte Werbung versuchen zu erhalten auch wenn das wieder aufgrund rechtlicher Perspektive sind macht,
noch macht eigentlich auch für die Medien Sinn weil 70 % der Kohle die da reingesteckt Witten dieses Werbesystem.
Und für all das wäre das Gesetz eine Lösung und deswegen haben wir auch ein Brief aufgesetzt den,
insgesamt 17 Organisationen aus Österreich unter anderem eben der c3w die Arbeiterkammer,
die größte Gewerkschaft in Österreich sich alle dafür ausgesprochen haben dass diese Verhandlungen jetzt endlich fortgeführt.
Freitag gestern also Varna Arbeitsgruppe imrad wir wissen noch nicht was passiert ist,
aber ich spreche auch deswegen drüber weil mit Öffentlichkeit das ist so einer der wenigen Punkte wo sie merken ok über,
Öffentlichkeit für ein EU Thema ist unüblich und wenn man das irgendwie immer wieder erwähnt dann,
wenn Sie das vor der Wahl nämlich nicht tun dann haben wir wirklich ein Problem.
Ant man sieht auch wiederum so schön wir haben vorüber sottisen dir die,
geredet und bei Arbeitslosen lieber mal kürzen,
wie sie haben jetzt auch bei der Ratspräsidentschaft,
letzte Woche die Priorität ausgerufen e-evidence ein überwachungsgesetz auf EU-Ebene unbedingt noch fertig zu verhandeln also bei der Überwachung muss es ganz schnell gehen aber sobald es um Grundrechte geht um die Menschen geht,
ist egal dann schieben sie es auf die lange Bank.
Was versprichst du denn von der von der e-privacy-verordnung.
Was ich mir wünschen würde ist dass diese idiotischen cookie Dialoge wo wir nur,
pawlowsche Hunde auf okay und geh weg klicken vielleicht so ein richtiges ja nein,
das sind wirklich die Wahl haben so will ich jetzt hier,
diesen Inhalt nutzen oder will ich dabei auch überwacht werden vielleicht eben auch die Option zahlen oder,
Pferden im besten Fall aber auch die Möglichkeit die Seite zu sehen und nicht persönlich hätte Werbung zu bekommen,
das wäre eigentlich die sinnvollste Variante davon,
Ammons das ganze Thema Cookie und Cookie Warnhinweise steckt da auch drinnen aber es geht noch um viel mehr und somit auch im Offline Tracking,
wenn du heute irgendwie durch manche Einzelhandelsketten läufst wirst du auch mit dem Blutdruck und deinem Wallfahrt von deinem Telefon gecheckt und dann sehen sie auch so vor welchen Regalen bleibst du stehen aber du interessierst dich für Windeln ok wird sag mir mal lieber die Werbung hier an,
und offline Tracking ist so einer der Bereiche wo es einfach noch ungleich wieder zu regeln ist und die Kommission ist eigentlich ganz mutig da drauf zugegangen und wollte da eine gute Regelung schaffen,
was auch drin steckt ist do-not-track also manche kennen das von Ihrem Browser dass man einstellen kann ich will nicht gecheckt werden es macht man einmal an und dann muss man auf den ganzen Webseite nicht extra sagen bitte nicht,
und das soll auch mit diesem Gesetz rechtlich verpflichtend werden und ist auch so eines der Dinge wo sich Österreich.
Ja ich weiß nicht ob das so weit genug geht musst du was sagen Florian.
Na ich würde da tatsächlich weiter gehen ich finde das total geil wenn es wenn man halt jetzt wirklich mit einer
tables mit ihm was diese ganze Tracking Sache angeht inklusive offline Tracking wenn es den ganzen Kram einfach aushebeln würde,
würde die Welt glaube ich gerade um 90% besser machen.
Glaube ich auch das ist natürlich nicht zu warm als die Industrie noch auf seiner Seite bekommt aber zusehends schauen also gerade Leute die die in diesem werbe Business groß sind sagen
Leute wir haben Problem das derzeitige System funktioniert nicht die Kohle geht auch nicht mehr dorthin wo Sie hin muss keiner kennt sich aus,
und damit guten Datenschutz Gegenpol zu bringen oder zumindest alternativer Ökosysteme aufzubauen für eigentlich.
Danach zuletzt wenn das Gesetz gestrichen wird was auch im Raum steht dann haben wir die schöne Situation dass du als Mobilfunkbetreiber,
mit dem gesamten Metadaten deiner Nutzer auch Rollschuhe monetarisieren kannst also dann kannst du so als Vodafone oder Deutsche Telekom hergehen und zum Dienst anbieten wo ist jeder jetzt gerade überhaupt und wer redet.
Also genau das was über der Vorratsdatenspeicherung für staatliche Zwecke speichern,
kann keine das mussten Wer daneben auch einfach ganz normal aus Monetarisierung denkbar du hast eine billige Wertkarte also billige SIM Karte aber dafür verkaufen wir halt deine Daten.
Also es gibt spezifische Regeln in der Übersicht Verordnung für den Telekom Bereich und würde die jetzige richtiger die wir noch haben,
gänzlich gestrichen werden dann hätten wir auf jeden Fall eine rechts Luke und das nur mit datenschutzgrundverordnung zu lösen würde ich mir nicht ganz zu.
Dabei wird die jetzt automatisch gestrichen auch wenn nichts Neues kommt oder.
Am automatisch nicht aber das ist was wir die ganze Zeit für ein von der Industrie das ist ja ein Ziel und da sind sich eben Telekom Industrie Facebook Apple Facebook Google sorry und und unter die Zeitungsverlage eine.
Aber wenn es jetzt keine keine Einigung gibt in dieser Legislatur.
Gericht den erhalten damit.
Schatzi erstmal ne okay.
Genau aber die Red und uns halt nicht von der Tracking Infrastruktur die es aktuell schon gibt.
Er ist schon klein Alfons noch mal klarstellen nicht dass er jetzt irgendwie automatisch auf irgendwas in,
laufen was finde ich wollt ich wär ein ich auch ganz froh wenn dieser ganze cookie Button Kram,
aber mal komplett von dem Webseitenbetreibern weggenommen als müssen vor den Seiten weggenommen wird,
und quasi Teil des Protokolls wird ja also warum muss ich da immer wieder ja oder nein sagen,
das kann ich halt auch meinen Browser automatisch tun lassen ich sitz halt einfach dann default,
werde gegebenenfalls darauf,
hingewiesen dass daneben irgendwas nicht funktioniert muss aber halt so erstmal nichts machen und der Browser verhindert das halt Auto,
da ist sicherlich noch eine Menge zu holen und dich gesagt mich da auch ganz zuversichtlich dass wir da langfristig Fortschritte erzielen weh.
Ja ich glaube so TUI des Datenschutzes ist das gestern rosa nicht zu Thema.
Quinting undsoweiterundsofort also die Cookies sind ja dann nur einen ein kleiner Teil von dem was tatsächlich ausgelesen wird durch diese App nicht
Netzwerke und das ist ja ja das große Problem dass es ein halt wirklich bis ins offline Leben hin
verfolgt und es komplette schattenprofile von allem gibt was wir überhaupt tun nur dadurch dass es eben diese Werbeindustrie gibt die dazwischen hängt und einfach sämtliche Daten die sie irgendwo kriegt wieder an bestimmten Knotenpunkten Match also zusammenführt,
und daneben,
was heißt es kann halt genauso gut sein dass irgendeine Firma.
Naja aber warum soll man sich groß darüber Gedanken machen dass die Unternehmen ihre Daten unsere Daten verkaufen,
wenn sie wenn man sie auch einfach so holen kann.
Bregenz am das war jetzt auch gerade unlängst mal wieder Thomas kannst du mir helfen wer hat's gesagt,
es war jetzt gerade bei dem Darwin Circle hier in Wien,
da hat er eine sie hat gesagt die Daten die er selber von seinen Kunden hat darf er aufgrund der dsgvo selbst nicht benutzen,
deswegen kauft einfach genau dieselben Daten von Google ein und deswegen können sie aufgrund dessen was sie eben wieder über ihre Kunden eingekauft haben weil sie die eingekauften Daten sind und nicht die eigenen deswegen können sie dann wieder irgendwie.
Kompletter Bullshit aber das passt zu dieser Veranstaltung von dir du sprichst der ich ich glaube das wird alles soweit es ist eine Lupen Industrie Veranstaltung unter anderem gesponsert von Palantir die vor ein paar Wochen war.
Naja also ich gerade sagte man kann sich die Daten ja auch Soho,
zeigt wie's gemacht wird.
Du musst nur wissen wie man fragt.
Nur so wissen wie man fragt und irgendwie ist das ja auch so ein bisschen so ein Wiedergänger
VHS im Rahmen des Standard Verhaltenstherapie,
wie sie vor ein paar Jahren eben noch,
funktioniert halt bei Facebook Ebene Lage war eben nicht nur Informationen über jemanden der in irgendeiner Seite gerade hinter agiert und Teile nimmt zu bekommen sollen eben auch für die Freunde und Freundesfreunde das ist natürlich dann alles abgeschaltet worden alles ist,
stellt sich raus.
Naja
die hatten also eine Reihe an an unterschiedlichen Bugs die nicht nur theoretisch irgendwie existiert man von jemandem gefunden wurden sondern die in der Form spezifisch ausgenutzt wurden und zwar,
jetzt wieder so eine Fangfrage ist hier jemand bei Facebook nicht der Fall.
Oh doch was der ganze Raum 15 Leute von ein paar.
Es gibt bei Facebook für alle anderen ein Feature,
gab es also man konnte da ich ihr redet ja wieder der Blinde von der Farbe
es ist so da konnte also quasi seine eigene Timeline oder die Timeline anderer quasi sich anschauen wie sie,
das jetzt hier aus für eine andere Person und
um quasi zu kontrollieren ob die eigenen,
sogenannten Privatsphäre-Einstellungen den auch Effekt haben ja also wenn man ihm gesagt jetzt möchte ich mal meine eigene Timeline sehen als Person B und damit prüfen ob er sich so ein B auf wirklich nicht ne Party Fotos sieht bei Person B,
jetzt schaue ich mir mal steemit mal den Tim und der Tim wäre jetzt mein Facebook Freund völlig hypothetisches.
Hypothetisch Vorstellung der Tim wäre jetzt mein Facebook Freund und ich würde und,
die Claudia wäre aber nicht meine Facebook Freundin und jetzt würde ich sagen,
gucke ich mir mal meine eigene Seite an als Tim.
Und durch eine Kombination von Bugs sage ich dann Facebook zeig mir doch mal die die Seite von der Claudia als Tim und in dem Moment würde claudia hat jetzt von mir ist ihre Einstellung so dass Leute mit den sie nicht befreundet ist sie gar nicht sehen können,
also wenn ich direkt sagen würde ich möchte Claudia Seite sehen Stunde da nicht,
kannst dich sehen du musst erst mal fragen ob ihr befreundet seid und so weiter wenn ich aber sag zeig mir noch,
dann würde Facebook sagen,
Montage sind befreundete schicken sich ja auch irgendwie claudia hat alles freigegeben,
dann bin ich jetzt einfach mal dauerhaft Tim und das funktioniert also so ein Login Verfahren
relativ,
naja also ich werde es verständlich man gibt einmal ein Passwort ein und bekommt dann einen Token zurück das ist quasi dann so einen shared secret kann in der Cookie in Form eines Cookies häufig einfach genutzt werden.
Damit man sich nicht jedes Mal neu einloggen muss ja damit einmal der login stattgefunden hat oder merkt Facebook sich wenn jemand kommt und hat diesen Toten dann ist diese Person schon hier angemeldet
und die hat man gleich auch noch dazu bekommen und die haben Angreifern dass er so ein tatsächlicher Angriff der hier durchgeführt wurde die Angreifer hatten also,
zu Beginn,
weniger Freunde auf Facebook haben sich die Freunde der Freunde angeschaut haben sich wieder welche ausgesucht haben sich die Freunde der,
österreichische Publikum die haben nicht alle Freunde,
dieser Freunde sich wieder angeschaut Saunieren noch eben welchen Kriterien eine Auswahl getroffen,
und sind deswegen auf eine Zahl zwischen irgendwie 30 und 50 Millionen Konten gekommen die in unterschiedlichen,
zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten von Facebook berichtet wurden und die da irgendwie betroffen waren.
Spannend ist weil wie finde ich raus ob ich betroffen war tatsächlich,
Facebook als sie festgestellt haben dass dieser Missbrauch stattgefunden hat das richtige getan nämlich alle Logins,
deep zu dem Zeitpunkt existierten.
Ungültig werden lassen das heißt alle Geräte die eingeloggt waren sind token nutzt z.b. auch eure facebook-app oder wenn ihr irgendein Browser eingeloggt war das ist dann ein anderer taugen.
Und am 28 September 20 18 haben sie dann alle,
alle Instanzen von den Betroffenen NutzerInnen ausgeloggt das heißt veniam,
20. September irgendwie überall ausgeloggt wird und nicht bei Facebook neu einloggen musstet,
dann herzlichen Glückwunsch ihr seid jetzt eine Angriffs Opfer einer noch nicht weiter geklärten Gruppierung geworden die dabei fest,
einige Daten rausgetragen hat in dem Fall,
leben im Moment ist so 30000000 ist glaube ich so die Überlieferung dir zumindest die aktuellste Zahl ist.
1000 Diner Kraftwerke einfach so durch radioaktive Wasser aus Rind und Obst ist und so passiert.
Oder wenn du Betreiber einer SSL library bist und feststellst dass es für den Login benötigt,
der kleine sagt ich habe den Login erfolgreich,
da müssen die Nutzerinnen jetzt,
leider durch aber ist natürlich in keiner Form irgendwie entschuldbar,
aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen sie solche Programmierfehler entstehen also das ist jetzt nicht das erste Mal dass es Menschen solche Programmierfehler gemacht haben und dafür sind natürlich auch Facebook
Google und Apple eben nicht gefeiert das sieht man an solchen Fällen eben wieder rund,
du siehst ja auf allen weitverbreiteten Plattform tatsächlich solche lächerlichen Programmierfehler na geht über go to fail dieses also so,
die Liste solcher Fehler ist lang und es ist eben glaube ich auch eine sehr
verrückte Annahme dass man so etwas durch Zertifizierungen oder mit oder Gesetze oder oder mehr Geld in irgendeiner Form wegbekommt.
Ich glaube das einzige wie du das weg bekommst sind halt oder wäre halt ein spontaner Nutzer Schwund aber der findet ja trotz allem nicht statt das ist ja das verwunderliche an der Sache.
Na gut aber jetzt ist ja Facebook im Prinzip in der Situation dass sie potenziell jetzt dafür bestraft werden können weil jetzt fallen sie unter die die,
bvona wir kennen das eine relativ hohe Summen jetzt müsste man ihn quasi nur nachweisen dass sie das,
Percy Formulierung fahrlässig getan haben
oh das wird jetzt ein interessanter Fall werden weil es die Forderung gibt es ja jetzt das Facebook einer Untersuchung wie heißt die europäische Agentur.
Ich glaub das waren die Iren die sich jetzt dieses Falles angenommen haben und die irische Datenschutzbehörde hat von sich aus Ermittlungen eingeleitet jetzt gegen Facebook.
Sieglar was gibt ja eine eine wie heißen diese Gruppe die das jetzt untersuchen soll das ist,
Sicherheits Fall die Zugriffe bräuchte ich deine Mann erschlagen aufjedenfall die gibt,
kann ein irgendwas mit E am Anfang natürlich was denkst du denn schon gleich noch mal,
so und dann ist halt eben die Frage was für ein Prozess,
weisen zu können dass eben eine solche fahrlässig Fahrlässigkeit vorliegt in dieser heißt die sicherheitsagent.
Und ja in dieser bist du jetzt im Prinzip Zugang zum Code bekommen müsste sie sich gezeigt bekommen was jetzt eigentlich der Grund war.
Also,
und dann dann müssen sie auch die Frage wenn man weiß was es war keiner irgendwo ein falsches, gesetzt sein und schon hast du sowas ne mit Jan ein Zugriff ist möglich ist nicht möglich wann er eigentlich eine Funktion hat mit,
schau's dir an als wäre wenn du ich wärst nur sei nicht x-so und wenn er irgendein einer einzigen Stelle,
dann falsches Zeichen steht dann,
bitte das jetzt rein vom Kot her schon diese Auswirkungen haben die Frage ist halt nur,
hätte es eine automatisierte testing geben müssen z.b. also ist in irgendeiner Form eine Fahrlässigkeit hier nachweisbar und letztenendes daneben auch aus Sicht des Parlaments gegeben und dann könnten halt auch,
RAV Massnahmen ergriffen werden.
Also ich ich glaube es muss ich hier Jahre Haft,
geben weil ich meine die die datenschutzgrund vorder hat er den risikoansatz,
unterschied lot of user data,
antanta facebook hat immer gesagt aber du kannst selber kontrollieren wer deine Daten sieht,
so einem Feature Force offensichtlich ist das dass du wirklich die größte,
genau hinzuschauen also das muss die wirklich teuer zu stehen kommen ansonsten werden wir unsere Gesetze nicht ernst nehmen oder.
Also ich glaube da wird überhaupt nichts passieren ich glaube ehrlich also das ist.
Denkt was wird jetzt einfach mal Premier eine Weile dauern einfach weil ganzen Prozesse so lange sind aber wenn das dann mal teuer wird glaube ich kann das dann schonmal zumindestens Zeichensatz.
Ja mal bitte wieder machen wir doch alle wir sind doch alle Menschen.
Ja das wird sie deswegen wird sie auch automatisiert testen hast du ein Algorithmus dahinter der macht das immer recht.
Ja vielleicht kriegen die ja auch einfach eine gratisfahrt in der partytram oder so und das Thema ist erledigt also,
ich meine wir sehen leider in in fast allen Bereichen solche groß,
also großflächiger unglaublicher fahrlässig,
Kite Nachlässigkeiten Rechte Verletzungen in in allen möglichen Dimensionen,
das ist ihm fi IT security Analysten gibt die besser darin sind einem solch mal weniger kompetenten,
wie auch immer gearteten Gremium zu erklären dass diese Schwachstelle fahrlässig war als Facebook Anwälte hat,
die den erklären warum das so nicht war und deswegen bin ich relativ also ich meinte ich freue mich die Wette zu verlieren,
aber ich wäre überrascht.
Also sind natürlich auch noch zwei Ebene du hast einerseits ob die Behörden wirklich das tun was sie tun sollten,
an das ist ganz auf dem Problem das kann ich selber ganz gut von der Netze 3,
das wird bei der irischen Datenschutzbehörde sicherlich auch nichts move gehen
aber dann hättest du ja immer noch den schönen Weg über die Betroffenen das sind die 30 Millionen über Schadensersatz zu klagen dafür haben wir ja die neue NWO von Max Schrems
die genau da eigentlich sich von der Feuerwehr Stange runter Herzens holt
und genau da aktiv werden soll ja also das glaube ich wär der zweite Weg dazu.
Bitte noch bisschen was zu der neuen enteo von Max Schrems sagen.
Du meinst jetzt wo ich da vier Monate gearbeitet.
Du hast große eine gute Einblicke ich will erst überrascht als du sagtest du hast nur 4 Monate da gearbeitet was sofort sagen das war 501 auch nur für vier Monate ausgelegt ihr seid nach wie vor.
Ja ja wir haben uns nicht gegenseitig umgebracht also ich habe jetzt 4 Monate mit Anwälten verbracht aber so schlimm war es nicht nein.
Epamax glaube ich auch schon die Messer oder.
Kann und darf dazu nichts sagen was sie jetzt nächstes vorhaben es würde mich allerdings sehr wundern wenn er das jetzt dann auslassen würde also.
Eso Verse wenn Max da dran ist der nämlich meine Sicherheit in der Wetten bisschen zurück.
Die werden jetzt weggeschwemmt.
Ich genau die ventildeckelschrauben ist.
Dann dann freuen wir uns alle und von dem Gewinn Gehen wir dann gemeinsam essen.
C&A könnt ja noch erwähnen Maxus gerade einen Entwickler,
der Bär irgendwie für Schrems arbeiten will und coole Tools banville wir verlinken da.
Es geht um so einen einfachen Facebook scraper.
Ich glaube tatsächlich auch um die Weiterentwicklung der Spendenplattform und da so ein paar andere Projekte die jetzt halt gerade noch offen sind die ich da jetzt die letzten vier Monate auch zum Teil mit an gestartet habe also,
mir da vielleicht noch was genaueres wissen will gerne nachher.
So wir überspringen die Kurzmeldungen Tim weil ich weiß dass es mit dir nie klappt Kurzmeldungen zu machen nein das geht mit dir nicht du du fängst du wieder an zu diskutieren und er denn es ist 19:30 Uhr und wären jetzt eine halbe Stunde überzogen und die nächste Sendung folgt,
andre wollte ja heute nicht auch noch mit auf die Bühne der hätte sich bestimmt auch noch ein bisschen.
Habe ich so ein schönes Bild rausgesucht von dem her.
So sieht unser Präsident des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz aus und das ist jemand der also Geheimagenten ihr kennt das aus dem Bonn Zeiten man lebt nur zweimal.
Der auch der ist vom paar Monaten gegangen worden oder vom Monat aber.
Verfassungs Kratzer mit sieben Leben.
Bitburg geklaute leben länger ich würde vorschlagen wir kommen jetzt zu den Termin ich bitte euch drei noch mal in die Scheune zum schauen damit wir jetzt auch das hier choreographiert kriegen.
Da habe ich ja mal gespannt.
Ich habe einen Anruf bekommen und ich sollte sollte bitte nach Frankfurt kommen zu der Veranstaltung 18 trifft 68 und ich habe erstmal gedacht so ich muss Ihnen was bitteres erzählen ich bin gar nicht,
68 und ich bin noch nicht 18 aber es ist natürlich 19288,
1968 eine Diskussion über 50 Jahre Entstehen des linken Widerstandes insbesondere auch in der Frankfurter Geschichte da bin ich am 31.10,
beschäftigt habe ich gesagt welche 68er denn,
und die Antwort am Telefon war also Herr Neumann die 68er das war eine linke Bewegung ok da habe ich dann lachend ab und damit übergebe ich an Tim.
Ja und der 35 C3 der 35 Chaos polycation Kongress in Leipzig steht wie ihr alle schon seit langen wisst.
Schrägstrich 35 C3 bringt euch hoffentlich ans Ziel.
Die Tickets sind natürlich wie immer heiß begehrt.
Ansehen welchem Kongress und der hat 30,
welche Abend in Wien wird am 8. November stattfinden,
Florian Zech von der TU Wien der über das AMS Thema Untergrund und sprechen wird,
was wir vorher schon gehört haben und ganz besonders freuen wir uns auf.
Die Maurer.
Genau ehemaliger Vorsitzender ehemalige national,
ordnete und aufgrund mehrerer Fehler von Hass im Netz gerade im Mittelpunkt von serientipp.
Lieber Hass im Netz und wie man sich dagegen wehren.
Soll das ganz am 8. November hast du schon gesagt.
November mal zum 30 wie immer im Metern ab.
Soll ich jetzt hier gerade mal eine ganz großspuriger ein ganz grossporige save-the-date sagen 21 bis 27 Oktober 2019 Check.
Boho.
Ja das bringt dann das Ende der Sendung.
Ja und da danken wir noch mal paskuda.
Claudia.
Danke auch.
Thomas steht auf der Teamseite Tim auch das war ich sowieso.
Salinas Neumann paw.
Dank Alter ist dank time doch niemand somit beenden wir die Folge 273 von Logbuch Netzpolitik,
live von der privacy week am27 Oktober 2018 aus Wien.
Vielen Dank fürs Kommen tschüss.